them of rules and rights that has made
Europe stronger and safer for more than
seven decades
but things haven't gone the way that the
Kremlin plan
Putin expected Ukraine to surrender
and he expected the world to submit
history
will record something very different
history will remember the courage of the
Ukrainian people
and history we'll remember the
determination and strength of the NATO
alliance
almost a year after Russia's Imperial
invasion of Ukraine
NATO is more unified and more Resolute
than ever
we are determined to stand with
Ukraine's Brave Defenders
for as long as it takes
and we are also determined to protect
every inch of NATO territory
Putin's flagrant aggression has changed
the security environment for every
member of this Alliance
and for countries around the world
you could see the scope of the Global
Response again yesterday
when some 50 nations of Goodwill
gathered for the ninth meeting of the
Ukraine defense contact group
and these challenges were an important
part of this NATO ministerial
we talked today about how to ensure that
NATO remains prepared to confront the
dangers ahead
at the Madrid Summit in June NATO
leaders agreed on a fundamental shift in
our Collective defense and deterrence
we are strengthening our capabilities
for the long term
to deter and defend against all threats
across all domains
we're upgrading our defense plans and
putting more forces at higher levels of
readiness
today we discuss the progress that we've
made since Madrid
and our ongoing work as we move towards
the Vilnius Summit in July
in Vilnius our leaders will agree on a
new defense investment pledge
to ensure that the alliance has the
resources
to carry out these new plans
we had productive conversations about
that pledge
and we look forward to working with our
valued allies to ensure that we all do
even more
to invest in our shared security
we also discussed our progress in
building up ammunition stockpiles
in boosting defense
industrial industrial capacity
and NATO allies have dug deep over the
past year
in both President Biden and I are deeply
grateful
but we still have much more to do
even as we rush to support Ukraine in
the critical months ahead
we must all replenish our stockpiles to
strengthen our deterrence and defense
for the long term
now this Alliance has always drawn
strength from its shared Devotion to the
values of Freedom democracy and human
rights
we've seen it in action over the past
year
is our extraordinary allies have stepped
up to condemn Putin to condemn Putin's
Imperial aggression
to support Ukraine's right to defend
itself and to Str to strengthen our
Collective defense
we will not be drawn into Putin's war of
choice
but we will never waver in carrying out
NATO's preeminent task
and that task is to defend this great
Alliance as people and their territory
America's commitment to that core
mission is unflinching
America's commitment to Article 5 is
Ironclad
and we're proud to work alongside our
NATO allies
to defend the forces of freedom
and to build a safer world
so thank you very much and I'll take a
few questions thank you Mr secretary our
first question will go to Tom secretary
redstone
thank you good afternoon Mr secretary
Sarah 1914 as troops invading France
moved through this very region those in
charge of the defense in Paris scrambled
to rush men and material to blunt that
offensive they had little time to react
and through everything they could
including taxi cabs to get what was
needed into the fight to counter that
offensive and they succeeded now for
NATO Secretary General on down many here
have acknowledged that the Russians have
even started or will soon begin an
offensive of some proportion before the
ukrainians can do the same so a similar
scramble seems to be looming yesterday
you outlined a deep and wide range of
Military Support pledged to Ukraine you
just mentioned it again today
but with ports jammed and Railways
clogged with some production off pace
how certain are you that this support
will get to Ukraine in time or as you
just said in your opening remarks
how will history record something very
differently thank you thanks Tom
what we're seeing from Russia is
Russia is
continues to pour large numbers of
additional people into the fight
and those people are ill-trained and
ill-equipped and because of that we see
them
incurring a lot of casualties and we'll
probably continue to see that going
forward that's that's their strength
they have a lot of people
our goal is to make sure that we give
Ukraine additional capability so that
they can be not only be marginally
successful they can be decisive on on
the battlefield in their upcoming
offensive and so you've seen us uh moved
to provide Bradley Fighting Vehicles
you've seen us uh move to provide
Strikers
Martyrs leopard tanks and a number of
other things that we're pulling together
to provide them additional capability
that I think will make a pretty
significant difference in their in their
counter-offensive in the spring
so we're laser focused on making sure
that we provide a capability and not
just platforms Tom
so
for every system that we provide we're
going to train troops on that system but
we're also going to give them additional
training on on maneuver on the
integration of fires on sustainment and
uh and on maintenance and so with that
additional capability better trained
troops platforms that can perform a lot
better in this environment I think
they'll have a real good chance at
making a pretty significant difference
on a battlefield and establishing the
the initiative and being able to exploit
that initiative going forward
thank you sir our next question will go
to David botey svergus television
uh thank you secretary Austin David
bowate from Swedish public television
regarding the session process do you
predict that both Sweden and Finland
will be members at the summit this
summer and is there something the United
States can do to help make that happen
well I certainly hope that they will
David and I know that uh you know all of
my colleagues feel the same way
they are ready to to join now and and
these are two countries that are highly
capable that bring a lot of value to the
alliance once they join
we have we've trained with them in the
past they've invested a lot in in
modernization and so they'll bring a lot
to the table now when and how they join
will be really up to the leadership of
both of those countries and I know that
leader their leadership is leaning
forward and so we'll see what happens I
I don't I want a hazard to predict I
would just tell you that I I know uh all
of my colleagues
are with me and saying that we'd like to
see them join as soon as possible
thank you sir and our final question
will go to Bill Hennigan Time Magazine
the last 24 hours we've heard that of
F-16 shot at and missed a flying object
over Lake Huron and that the objects
themselves May likely be for research or
some other benign reason
given that there's been no other shoot
Downs in the past two days after we had
three in a row
is the military now more wary to engage
these objects and then secondly it seems
that the debris is located in some hard
to reach places to put it lightly
so how important is the recovery of this
wreckage into
um to the to deciding the policy ahead
well I'm not aware of any additional
objects that have been reported uh
operating in the space in the last 48
hours so
um but in terms of whether or not the
debris is is important it's absolutely
important and we're going to do
everything we can to recover debris if
it's possible
um that will help us learn a lot more
about you know what these objects are
we're also working with other agencies
NASA FAA FBI and and everybody in the
community who may have a an interest in
operating in this space to learn more
about uh you know what what these could
have possibly been and so I would just
tell you that the Safety and Security of
the American people uh that's uh that's
the thing that's most important to me
and to everybody on on the dod team and
throughout the interagency so we're
going to continue to drill until we
until we learn as much as we can about
uh about you know what these objects are
and why they were operating in those
spaces uh we will always air on the side
of caution but uh but again
there's a lot to be learned going
forward so
thank you very much sir ladies and
gentlemen that is all the time we have